Leute der prank heute ne wird der mit
Abstand meiner Ansicht nach lustigste
prank den wir je gemacht haben let's go
ich kann irgendwie nicht schlafen ich
schon
wie lange schlafen wer ist denn noch
hier drauf Luca
bei mir steht Null von drei Spielern
schlafen was machst du hier ich kann
nicht auf mein Bett drücken weil oder
bist du Sandra kannst sein dass Du mit
beiden Accounts drin bist das geht doch
gar nicht
oh mein Gott der Ultimate wendem hat den
Fortschritte wer ist das
oh mein Gott
warum keine Ahnung
ich habe fast kein Leben mehr hey das
ist kein prank Leute ich schwöre der
prank war jetzt nicht dass sie
plötzlichen Wald brennt oder irgendwas
ey sandiges ist zu dritt ey das ist
nicht der prank was ist denn das auch
für ein gruseliges Gesicht Luca
teleportiert dich mal zu ihm ja wenn er
irgendwo in der Luft ist dann bin ich ja
tot wo bist du denn Handy lass zusammen
bleiben bitte wo im Wald
[Musik]
ich habe kein op-rechte
behalten Venom Hacker aber ihr kennt
doch die IP nicht Sandy lass mal in dein
Haus schnell in dein Haus schnell bevor
irgendwas passiert kommst du ja
dann einfach ich habe keine op-rechte
ich habe den Server nicht aufgesetzt
keine Ahnung Leute was machen wir jetzt
ich habe auch voll schiss irgendwas zu
gucken gerade
oh mein Gott guck mal das Gesicht an
ab wie soll ich denn abschießen warte
ich will gar nicht hier rausgehen
Schwert in der Hand
das ist der stärkste Schwert der ist
hier das Handy der läuft hier rum
[Musik]
hä warum liegt denn das so ein fettes
ist das nicht dieses dieses Teil von so
einem
Leute was ist das
in drei zack
er sein jetzt verarscht meine ich ist
das einer von dir oder so ich schwöre es
dir ich habe eine Idee
weißt du was wir machen Boot fahren
dann komm hast du eins schnell schnell
schnell schnell schnell laufen immer
schnell bisschen was zu essen mit wir
fahren jetzt einfach weg
keine Ahnung irgendwo weg von dieser
Insel wurde uns nicht sieht weil er hat
ja keine Rechte der kann sich nicht
teleportieren wir fahren jetzt erstmal
in die Richtung weil da vorne in den
Wald kennen wir alles okay ja Leute wir
haben kein Kompass und wir haben kein
Bett
einer von uns beiden muss zurückgehen
ich hole ich hole unsere Betten und
Kompass gib mir eine Minute
ich darf auch extra einen anderen Weg
neben dem Weg her dass sie uns nicht
sieht aber im Zweifel schaut er ja sogar
den Stream
ernsthaft jetzt eine Person haben die
sich hier eingeloggt hat der ist auch
immer noch drauf wir haben keinen
Kompass Leute jetzt mal ganz kurz wir
brauchen eure Hilfe das ist jetzt nie
das ist jetzt kein Monster oder
irgendwie sowas
was
[Musik]
mit dem Boot an der Insel vorbei ich hol
schnell unsere Bett nicht komm zu dir
ich hole ein neues Boot ich mache
schnell ein neues AIDS Handy jetzt
wirklich verarschen mich bitte nicht
[Musik]
drin
oh mein Gott wo bist du wo bist du wo
bist du
oh mein Gott
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kaputt gemacht schreib im Chat was
willst du
ja ultimate werden falls du den Stream
hörst oder schaust dann schreib mal
bitte in den Chat
warum schreibt eine Pflaume
[Musik]
bringt nicht seid ja der fliegt ja der
der Creative Mode an seiner hier
schreiben Leute ich wusste von Anfang an
dass es malik ist das ist nicht Malik
wer ist das
[Musik]
bitte ich frage was er will
er schreibt einfach nur
ihr dürft nicht schlafen Erwachen nur
nachts ah das heißt wenn Tag wird ist er
weg da müssen wir uns nur irgendwie
sicherstellen oder wir gehen halt vom
vom Server einfach runter
ja ich bin runter aber erst noch drauf
was sollen wir denn jetzt machen ich
kenne niemanden der diese Daten hat
oh mein Gott ich kann doch jemanden
diesen Server den ich der das war ja der
Server den ich vorher mit Sirio hatte wo
wir gezockt haben kann sein dass der das
doch ist dass er seinen Namen geändert
hat weil er hieß früher Sirion 01 wir
packen Siri jetzt hier in den Call rein
ich rufe den jetzt an ich rufe den jetzt
an wenn der das ist ne was machst du
[Musik]
jetzt for real
bist du gerade in Minecraft
dann habe ich dann habe ich keine Ahnung
wer das ja aber okay gut Bro dann viel
Spaß ne aber der sagt ja bei Tag ist ja
nicht mehr da
macht er denn jetzt bei Tag bei Tag
chillt und wir können unser Ding machen
und dann kommt der wieder wenn Nacht ist
oder wie wollen wir es einmal testen
wollen wir noch 8 Minuten bis der Tag
vorbei ist in Minecraft dann lass uns
jetzt am Tag kurz unsere Sachen machen
aber der war ja auch gar nicht mehr da
gucken ob der noch da ist noch da also
du kannst der Tab gedrückt halten
den heiligen schönen Tag bis die Nacht
an bricht Sandra hey ich schwöre wenn du
mich verarscht dann machst du gerade
richtig gut nein du verarschst mich was
soll ich denn machen
junge du ekliger hey mein prank war so
krank aber die machen wir wann anders
das werde ich jetzt nicht sagen aber was
das gerade ist ich dachte das wäre jetzt
von Sandra aber ich glaube ihr
mittlerweile bei Sander kann nicht
schauspielern eigentlich wird viel zu
viel lachen eigentlich jetzt sandra ist
das wirklich nicht malik
ist der einzige der auch noch Zugriff
hat auf diesen Server weil du damals
über seinen PC da drauf warst aber ich
bin doch gerade auf dem PC drauf
probiert die Welt und macht so eine neue
wieso fliegst du überhaupt ja also an
alle die wirklich jetzt gerade Ahnung
haben von Minecraft helft mir bitte kurz
kann ich in die Nitrado Server Konsole
gehen und dann irgendwie in der
Benutzerverwaltung das irgendwie machen
[Musik]
ja
da mache ich darüber einfach sicher ja
Lukas kein Server Operator mehr nein
das ist jetzt nicht wahr
[Musik]